cercana a la costa oeste de África.
Y luego pueden ver el breve resumen de cada uno de esos candidatos,
el cual espero realmente que sea muy neutral,
muy informativo y muy conciso.
Y cuando hayan encontrado el que les gusta, votan.
Estos fueron los candidatos
en las recientes elecciones presidenciales de Islandia,
y así es cómo funciona.
Entonces, ¿por qué diablos querrían votar en las elecciones de otro país?
Bueno, la razón por la cual no querrían hacerlo,
no se preocupen,
es para no interferir en los procesos democráticos de otro país.
Ese no es el propósito en absoluto.
De hecho, no se puede,
porque usualmente publico los resultados
después que el electorado de cada país ya haya votado,
así que no hay forma de interferir en ese proceso.
Pero lo más importante,
no estoy particularmente interesado
en los asuntos internos de cada país.
Eso no es por lo que estamos votando.
Lo que Donald J. Trump o Hillary Clinton
propongan hacer por los estadounidenses,
francamente no es asunto nuestro.
Eso es algo que únicamente los estadounidenses pueden decidir.
No, en el Voto Global, solo se considera un aspecto de ello:
¿Qué van hacer esos líderes por el resto de nosotros?
Y eso es muy importante porque vivimos,
—seguramente están hartos de que la gente lo diga—
en un mundo globalizado, hiperconectado, masivamente interdependiente
donde las decisiones políticas de la gente de otros países
pueden y tendrán un impacto en nuestras vidas.
No importa quiénes seamos, no importa dónde vivamos.
Como las alas de la mariposa,
batiendo en un lado del Pacífico,
que aparentemente pueden crear un huracán del otro lado,
así es el mundo donde vivimos hoy y el mundo de la política.
Ya no hay una línea divisoria
entre los asuntos nacionales y los internacionales.
En cualquier país, por pequeño que sea,
incluso si es Santo Tomé y Príncipe,
podría nacer el próximo Nelson Mandela
o el próximo Stalin.
Podrían contaminar la atmósfera y los océanos, que nos pertenecen a todos,
o podrían ser responsables y ayudarnos a todos.
Y sin embargo, el sistema es tan extraño
porque está desfasado de esta realidad globalizada.
Solo un pequeño número de personas puede votar por esos líderes,
aunque su impacto es gigantesco
y casi universal.
¿Qué número era?
140 millones de estadounidenses votaron
por el próximo presidente de EE. UU.,
y aún así, como todos sabemos, dentro de unas pocas semanas,
alguien le entregará los códigos de lanzamiento nuclear a Donald J. Trump.
Si eso no tiene un impacto potencial en nosotros,
no sé qué lo tendrá.
Asimismo, en el referéndum del voto del Brexit
solo unos cuantos millones de británicos votaron,
pero sea cual fuere el resultado de la votación,
habría tenido un impacto significativo
en las vidas de decenas y cientos de millones de personas de todo el mundo.
Pero solo unas cuantas personas pudieron votar.
¿Qué clase de democracia es esa?
Grandes decisiones que afectan a todos
tomadas por un número de personas relativamente pequeño.
Y no sé ustedes,
pero no creo que sea muy democrático.
Solo intento aclararlo.
Como les decía, no preguntamos sobre cosas internas.
De hecho, solo les hago dos preguntas a todos los candidatos.
Siempre envío las mismas dos preguntas.
Les pregunto, la primera,
si lo eligen: ¿Qué va a hacer por el resto de nosotros,
por los restantes 7 mil millones que vivimos en este planeta?
Segunda pregunta:
¿Cuál es su visión del futuro de su país en el mundo?
¿Qué rol tendría?
A todo candidato le envío estas preguntas.
No todos responden. No me malentiendan.
Creo que si contiendes para convertirte en el próximo presidente de EE. UU.
quizá estés muy ocupado la mayor parte del tiempo,
así que no me sorprende que no todos respondan, pero muchos lo hacen.
Más cada vez.
Algunos hacen más que responder.
Algunos responden de la forma más entusiasta
y más fascinante que se puedan imaginar.
Quiero referir aquí a Saviour Chishimba,
un candidato en las recientes elecciones presidenciales de Zambia.
Sus respuestas a estas dos preguntas
fueron básicamente una disertación de 18 páginas
sobre su visión del papel potencial de Zambia en el mundo
y en la comunidad internacional.
Lo publiqué en la página web, para que todos pudieran leerlo.
Saviour ganó el Voto Global,
pero no ganó las elecciones de Zambia.
Así que me pregunto,
¿Qué haré con este extraordinario grupo de personas?
Tengo aquí gente maravillosa que ganó el Voto Global.
Por cierto, siempre nos equivocamos.
El que elegimos
nunca es la persona elegida por el electorado nacional.
Eso debe ser en parte a que siempre tendemos a elegir a la mujer.
Pero también debe ser un indicio
de que el electorado nacional todavía piensa a nivel nacional.
Todavía piensan para sus adentros.
Todavía se preguntan: ¿En qué me beneficio yo...?
en lugar de preguntarse hoy,
¿en qué nos beneficiamos nosotros?
Ese es el problema.
Si quieren sugerir algo, por favor, ahorita no,
pero envíenme un correo si tienen alguna idea
sobre lo que podemos hacer con este grupo de gloriosos perdedores.
(Risas)
Tenemos a Saviour Chishimba, lo mencioné antes,
a Halla Tómasdóttir,
2° lugar en las elecciones presidenciales de Islandia.
Muchos de ustedes la habrán visto en su increíble charla en TEDWomen,
hace unas semanas
donde habló de la necesidad de más mujeres en la política.
Tenemos a Maria das Neves de Santo Tomé y Príncipe.
Tenemos a Hillary Clinton; no sé si esté disponible.
Tenemos a Jill Stein.
Y también cubrimos las elecciones
para el próximo Secretario General de las Naciones Unidas.
Tenemos al exprimer ministro de Nueva Zelanda,
sería un excelente miembro del equipo.
Quizá esta gente,
el club de los gloriosos perdedores, pueda viajar por el mundo
a donde haya elecciones,
para recordarle a la gente de la necesidad en nuestra sociedad moderna
de pensar un poco más hacia afuera
y de pensar en las consecuencias internacionales.
¿Y ahora qué sigue?
Bueno, obviamente,
el show de Donald y Hillary es un poco difícil de seguir,
pero vienen más elecciones muy importantes.
De hecho, parecen multiplicarse.
Está pasando algo en el mundo y de seguro lo han notado.
Y la siguiente ola de elecciones es seriamente importante.
En tan solo unos días se repetirán las elecciones presidenciales austriacas,
con Norbert Hofer como prospecto a convertirse en lo que se describe
como el primer jefe de Estado de extrema derecha en Europa
desde la Segunda Guerra mundial.
El próximo año tendremos a Alemania, Francia,
las elecciones presidenciales en Irán
y una docena más.
No es que se vuelvan menos importantes
sino que se hacen más y más importantes.
Claramente, el Voto Global no es un proyecto autónomo.
No se vale por sí solo.
Tiene un trasfondo.
Es parte de un proyecto que empecé en el 2014,
el cual llamo «El País Bueno» (Good Country).
La idea del País Bueno es muy sencilla.
Es mi simple diagnóstico de lo que está mal en el mundo
y de cómo podemos arreglarlo.
Ya di a entender lo que está mal en el mundo.
Básicamente, estamos ante un número enorme y creciente
de retos globales gigantescos existentes: el cambio climático,
la violación de derechos humanos, la migración masiva,
el terrorismo, el caos económico, la proliferación de armas.
Todos estos problemas que amenazan con acabarnos son,
por naturaleza, problemas globalizados.
Ningún país tiene la capacidad de abordarlos por sí mismo.
Y de esta manera, evidentemente
tenemos que cooperar y colaborar como naciones
para poder solucionar estos problemas.
Es tan evidente y sin embargo no lo hacemos.
No lo hacemos ni siquiera con la suficiente frecuencia.
La mayor parte del tiempo, los países aún insisten en comportarse
como si estuvieran en guerra; tribus egoístas luchando entre ellas,
como lo hacían antes de que el estado nacional fuera creado
hace cientos de años.
Y esto tiene que cambiar.
No se requiere un cambio del sistema político o un cambio de ideología,
sino un cambio cultural.
Todos nosotros tenemos que entender
que pensar solo en nosotros no soluciona los problemas mundiales.
Tenemos que aprender cómo cooperar y colaborar mucho más
y competir solo un poco menos.
Si no, las cosas van a seguir estando mal
y van a empeorar mucho más, más pronto de lo previsto.
Este cambio solo sucederá si nosotros, gente ordinaria,
le decimos a nuestros políticos que las cosas han cambiado.
Tenemos que decirles que la cultura ha cambiado.
Tenemos que decirles que tienen un nuevo mandato.
El antiguo mandato era muy sencillo e individual:
si se tiene poder o autoridad,
se es responsable de su propia gente y de su pequeño territorio, y ya.
Y si con el fin de hacer lo mejor para su pueblo,
se le afecta a las demás personas en el planeta, mejor aún.
Eso es considerado como ser un «macho».
Creo que hoy todos en una posición de poder y responsabilidad
tiene un doble mandato,
el cual dice, que si se tiene poder y responsabilidad
se es responsable de su propio pueblo,
y de cada hombre, mujer, niño y animal en el planeta.
Se es responsable de su propio territorio
y de cada kilómetro cuadrado en la superficie de la Tierra
y su atmósfera arriba.
Y si no le agrada esa responsabilidad, no debería estar en el poder.
Para mí esta es la regla de la modernidad
y ese es el mensaje que tenemos que enviarle a nuestros políticos,
y mostrarles que así se hacen las cosas hoy en día.
Si no, todo será un caso perdido.
En realidad, no tengo problema
con la ideología de Donald Trump de «EE.UU. Primero».
Me parece que es una declaración bastante banal
de lo que los políticos siempre han hecho y quizá deban hacer.
Por supuesto que la gente los elige para que representen sus intereses.
Pero lo que encuentro tan aburrido y tan anticuado
y tan poco innovador en su perspectiva,
es que «EE.UU. Primero» significa que los demás quedan a lo último,
que hacer grande de nuevo a EE. UU. es hacer a los demás a menos otra vez,
y eso no es cierto.
Como asesor político en los últimos 20 años, o más,
he visto cientos de ejemplos de políticas
que armonizan las necesidades internacionales y nacionales
y hacen una política mejor.
No estoy pidiendo a las naciones ser altruistas o abnegadas.
Eso sería ridículo.
Ninguna nación lo haría jamás.
Les estoy pidiendo que despierten y entiendan
que necesitamos una nueva forma de gobierno, la cual es posible,
que armonice esas dos necesidades,
las buenas para nuestro pueblo y las buenas para todos los demás.
Desde las elecciones en EE. UU. y del Brexit
se ha vuelto más y más evidente para mí
que esas viejas distinciones de izquierda y derecha
ya no tienen sentido.
Realmente no se ajustan al patrón.
Lo que parece importar hoy es muy simple,
si su visión del mundo es
reconfortarse al vivir en sí mismos y añorar el pasado,
o si, igual que yo, encuentran esperanza
mirando hacia adelante y hacia el exterior.
Esa es la nueva política.
Esa es la nueva división que separa al mundo, justo en el medio.
Eso puede sonar crítico, pero no es mi intención.
No malinterpreto en absoluto
el porqué mucha gente se siente a gusto mirando hacia adentro y hacia atrás.
Cuando los tiempos son difíciles y falta el dinero,
cuando uno se siente inseguro y vulnerable,
volverse introspectivo es una tendencia humana natural,
pensar en sus propias necesidades
y descartar las de los demás,
y quizá imaginar que el pasado de algún modo fue mejor
que el presente o de lo que el futuro podría ser algún día.
Pero creo que eso es un callejón sin salida.
La historia nos muestra que lo es.
Si la gente se torna hacia sí y hacia atrás,
el progreso humano retrocede
y ciertamente las cosas empeoran para todos muy rápidamente.
Si Uds. son como yo,
y creen en lo que está adelante y afuera,
y creen que lo mejor de la humanidad es su diversidad,
y lo mejor de la globalización
es la forma en que provoca esa diversidad, esa mezcla de culturas,
al hacerlas más creativas, más emocionantes, más productivas
de lo que ha existido antes en la historia de la humanidad,
entonces, amigos míos, tenemos trabajo que hacer,
porque la brigada del interior y del retroceso
están más unidas que nunca,
y esa ideología del interior y retroceso, ese miedo, esa ansiedad,
que juegan con los más básicos instintos, está expandiéndose en todo el mundo.
Aquellos que creemos, como lo hago yo,
en lo de adelante y en lo de afuera,
tenemos que organizarnos,
porque el tiempo se agota muy, muy rápido.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)